i believe there's a lot of power  when people of influence  their words have more power from the  pulpit when they say things and  someone's standing in the audience and  the parents said that's the priest  that's the pastor i think sometimes  people use that power too much and they  hurt people and they heard them  permanently for a long time and it  messes their mouth up  and that that that upsets me a lot a lot  it ups because i've seen this myself  so for me  if i know there's power in imagination  if i know there's power in positive  words  it's it's more  about trying to get that encouragement  for people to believe  you know  you have control of your life you can do  something with your life